for all the trolls out there thinking
that this is real [ __ ] hot sauce go
get [ __ ] but hey what's going on
everybody for first we feast I'm Sean
Evans and you're watching hot ones the
show with hot questions and even hotter
wings and today I'm joined by Matty
Matheson he has a new show dead set on
life you can see it on Vice land and for
our Canadian viewers there's a
restaurant Toronto parts the parts and
labor parts and labor
I come from the world everyone's welcome
not just Canadians you guys don't make
him show ID at the like yeah we got a
restaurant in Toronto but the world's
welcome to come and enjoy the food I
like that policy how are you with hot
food I'm okay
I had a SAN type 150 smart earlier just
to kind of get a base going one of the
hardest things I've ever done was at
this restaurant I we used to work at and
I was like hammered one night and I like
ate a taco pho just scorpion pepper
sauce and I started like throwing up and
like pouring a bag of milk on my head
and just like it wasn't like a it was a
night room that's the thing about hot
sauce is it will humble you yeah
wherever you think you are especially
when you're drunk in you're feeling
yourself you'll go that extra miles
hot sauce bar hey you die
this first one is sriracha sriracha is
no big deal plus your food guys ya know
what's up yeah let's do it
sriracha tres yummy you do these
unpretentious no-frills food tutorials
on munchies that I watch all the time
yeah and so what I'm hoping I can do it
just bounce a couple common bachelor
scenarios off of you and you can give me
some advice all right that's good number
one dish to impress a lady something
like light just like a lemon in like
ricotta spaghetti like if you could do
something like kind of delicate and then
like do it well and then she's eating
and she's like she feels light she feels
good she feels full maybe you you guys
can like 69 or like hang out watch movie
while strange things like whatever you
want to do that's smart because if you
do something heavy then maybe end up on
couch lock and yeah you're gonna
someone's kind of APE and then they're
gonna [ __ ] you know it's gonna be
dark you don't want that what's the
secret to a perfect grilled cheese
medium medium heat you know making sure
that you take your time and let the
crust of the of the bread caramelize
slowly a lot of people just turn on a
high heat and a lot of people get like
burnt grilled cheeses so it's just like
you don't crank it make it quick you
just put it on medium let the pan warm
up and then you put it in and just let
it sizzle and like do its thing and let
it like it crunchy then the cheese melts
better then you flip and you let it
chill get crispy good but I think
medium-high heat best dish to cure a
hangover I like like ramen or foie
or like go to Chinatown get some like
duck soup or something you know maybe
some congee that's like I like that
concept maybe like an orange Krush
always helps I feel
pretty good yeah geez which shows would
you say kind of influenced yours cuz I
noticed in the intro sometimes I feel
like I'm about to watch jackass and then
the show anything I love jackass I could
tell like in high school me and my
buddies had a thing called the fun
dummies and we used to like videotape or
you try to like I would go to a bar when
I was like 16 and I try to fight a
bouncer more like weave yeah just like
get beat up by like get knocked out by a
bouncer and we'd video in or like we
drive around on the top of cars driving
into like people's front lawns like
during when there's like big snow banks
like do stuff like that or whatever [ __ ]
around high school with video cameras
but we were like so this is amazing like
jackass is the best I think those guys
paved away you know it's a huge
inspiration obviously you know like I'm
like yeah what's up I'm Annie it's like
the same day like what's up I'm johnny
Knoxville
like my whole thing is like ripping off
Johnny dollars Johnny
real nice this one's the chili habanero
algo Yucatec Oh Lu katako
in the SS catch you on Episode you say
offhandedly that you've lost so many
teeth that your father-in-law yeah I
won't even work on you anymore he's a
dentist
yeah bill Bobby bill one day I wasn't
even like drunk or anything I was riding
my bike home from work and to get into
Parkdale there's kind of like a hill and
so like I'm like riding my bike up the
hill and you get to like the last thing
where you like stand up and do the like
kind of like a pedal and my my ID like
this old I kind of grandma cruiser bike
thing I like broke the pedal off and
like ate [ __ ] over the handlebars like
dusted my front like the whole top row
of my teeth just like dusted and then I
think just for my partying or like
panning like like mosh pit you know like
going to hardcore shows I used to like
wash with like a beer or something I
have like dusted my teeth or like open
beers with my teeth I don't drink
anymore but like I used to be a little
bit of a nut bags I had like this crazy
like this tooth forever was just like a
half tooth and I just looked super
gnarly and I was gonna get married to
Trish and I was just like it's like one
more time bill can we do that one more
freebie I got a free tooth and he's like
let's go
and that's the last time I've been kind
of a little more I'm I'd like to crack
at beers with my teeth or like get in
fights or anything so there you go hi
Steve
number four how you doing so far I'm
good I feel like it's there's chicken
wings with hot sauce that's good that
you say that because we have a whole
group of conspiracy theorists that watch
the show and think that this thing's
phony that there's not actually sauce on
the wings
no there's every single cell you can
taste like their sauce obviously like a
lot of people who work for Vice you have
an amazing Instagram because if you know
it sent you to all over the world yeah
so what we've done is we've done a deep
dive on your Instagram we pulled a
handful of ones that we like a lot and
we just need an explanation we just need
more context we need to know what's
going on okay that's all good yeah buddy
ah my buddy you're at the SkyDome I'm at
the sky down with my sign Mac his first
ball game his first ball game you threw
out the first pitch threw out the first
pitch I don't know anything about sports
so I was just like I didn't know
anyone's name I just knew that Bochy I
was like when do I mean Bautista and
they're like you don't meet Bautista I'm
like okay who's that guy like that's ace
I'm like who's a something like the
mascot I'm like I've lived in Toronto
for 16 years and I've been to two
baseball games and I've been escorted
out of both sometimes when people make
especially bad first pitches yeah that
makes every website out there it doesn't
matter what the outlet is like yeah
everybody covers bad first pitches were
you at all nervous that you might have
an epically bad first pitch that would
be bummed because I wasn't nervous
because it's throwing a baseball and I'm
like I'm gonna hold in my hand I'm gonna
throw it'll be fine but I was like do I
do something do I like door I'm like I
guess I asked that I was like well I'll
get in trouble if I take my shirt off
and like throw it or like can I like
kick it and she's like what she's like
go out and throw the baseball and walked
right back here and I was like yes ma'am
and then like people were tripped like
they're like [ __ ] nice high ball and
I was like I got over the plate it was a
little high I was like I smoked it over
the plane I was like it was a sick pitch
dawg get off of me next one is you and
razor haha yo
so this I I was driving down the street
his thing was like kind of broken
so was it working he was kind of
dragging it I was like do you want a
ride to like your hotel he's like okay
and so then I like gave him a ride down
to the Thompson where he was staying and
we just kind of hung out and exchanged
each other's numbers I got him a guy to
get him some weed and like we just like
hung I don't know it was great like I
have his number and Jimmy we've texted a
few times and [ __ ] but like super funny
like I was like yo that's that [ __ ]
kid from the [ __ ] thing is like the
like bone and criss cross or some [ __ ]
how about this one dog sled nuna vu kind
of looks like did a radish or something
wait when I hear the moon out there so
we shot an episode about food security
up in Nunavut
these are Huskies like that then
whatever you're over here North Mary
those aren't Huskies these are real
[ __ ] goddamn Huskies they and they're
running and then the like get close to
each other in two like ah and like fight
each other and like go and then like the
guy who was with me this big French dude
he was like he jumps on like grabs I'm
gonna separate this like it was really
intense like they are like it looks like
I got like a dog fight and I got one
more these pop-up every once in a while
you're kind of a cereal poster when it
comes to this situation it's the arm
John naked selfie I love you no shadings
good yep healthy yep um sharing that
with other people letting them know I'm
regular I'm doing okay it's more just
like a like a thumbs up this one is the
hot ones hot sauce you're on a show
called hot one so if you do the math
there this is your hot - this is our hot
sauce and that's right in the middle
you're like I don't want it to be too
spicy but I still wanted to be flavorful
I want people to taste it you're
actually right on the same wavelength
with me right now it's a turning point
sauce we wanted something that has a
little bit of heat cuz hot ones fans
that want a little bit of heat right but
then it's also kind of sweet because we
just want it to be a good sauce but if
it's not a good sauce Maddie you're a
chef let me know that it's not a good
sauce like I want your honest opinion
it's trash
I think it's too sweet there's garb
vinegary tasty I think it's a fair
criticism of our sauce it's tasty agree
speaking of kitchens you once described
the first one that you worked in there's
a pirate ship can you tell me about some
of the pitfalls of being in the kitchen
or some of the traps that are there for
chefs if you're not careful you don't
check those for young chefs it was like
a very cool place for like a young kind
of like punk hardcore kid and I was like
what were these people these people are
crazy and I was like I love drinking
partying and it was just like one of
those places like you'd show up for
brunch and you just like grab a pint of
like you know truly which is like a
strawberry Bavarian beer you drink like
ten of those during brunch and then all
the sudden you just started drinking
whenever all the time and then dog side
near you know head back bags giving lots
of cocaine right the kitchen it can be
like kind of a wolf of wallstreet kind
of environment and handed back in the
day like you know the chef was like this
like rockstar guy who was like drinking
bottles and like [ __ ] chicks and like
all this thing very bro vibe right and I
think like that's really changing for
the better that's what we're getting
spicy now yeah we are it's real all
right so food can sometimes be one of
the snobbiest forms of expression both
of the people who make it and for the
people who eat it you kind of run
counter to that rarefied sort of food
culture air yet you run with some of the
best chefs in the world I wonder do you
ever feel underestimated or do you ever
feel looked down upon for being kind of
different in that world for sure I think
it's um now this alive is hot right yeah
you know like I'm putting myself out
there as um not an anti chef but like
anti food television
I hate hi I'm a really good-looking guy
and this is how you make creme brulee
and this is perfect and then we're in
this beautiful backdrop of this
beautiful [ __ ] French house that's
owned by some millionaire and it's so
whitewashed and so [ __ ]
sorry your spicy mm-hmm oh yeah amen
it's starting to run through the body
how long is always a journey how long's
is yeah it's good it's good and you know
I think it's um everything so like oh
this is so beautiful oh if you could be
here and smell things everything isn't
the best everything [ __ ] isn't
beautiful oh my god these herbs is like
it's tarragon calm down
that kind of stuff kind of irks me but
that's whatever okay pain one hundo this
is pain 100 percent to me probably the
worst tasting hot sauce it looks like
jelly right [ __ ] okay I think that
somebody who has as many tattoos as you
do I'm sure that some of them are
thought-out and deliberate and then I'm
sure that others were sort of impulse
the spirit of the moment decision so I
have like a thousand questions about
your tats okay from I would say like the
nipples up which tattoo means the most
to you McCarthy I just got my son's name
tattooed on me Mac
that means the most that's like the best
one how about from the nipples up which
tattoo would you redo if you could just
below my nipples yeah but let's go just
below my nipple I have the worst tattoo
of my body but it's one of the most
meaningful I was in Albuquerque and my
sister was going through a bunch of
[ __ ] with her ex-husband who's a
piece of [ __ ] she was just going through
a really rough time and I was in
Albuquerque and I was far away from her
and I was like you know as I'm gonna get
a tattoo with like harp don't says Sara
and then I'll take a photo and be like
Sara I kind of tattoo I love you and
love much that you know like just like
I'm really like positive vibe kind of
thing and I got this tattoo it is the
worst it's just like so but and I got in
Albuquerque by some [ __ ] method or
something like I got it tattooed and
there's like 300 cool
I was just like where the [ __ ] you
coming from I get tattooed often and I
just like that's not a $300 tattoo this
took an hour like and it's like crazy
you didn't do what I wanted and I was
just like I was like I have 80 bucks and
I was just like you want to get nuts
like let's get nuts
I have 80 bucks and I was like I'm
walking out of here and your mental and
I already regret it is the one see it
yeah I do you see that Sarah I love you
still she's the best shares all single
moms out there the bomb the bomb beyond
us is like the biggest [ __ ] waste of
time like name [ __ ] stuff ever the
bull they all has people are crazy
they all have to out market each other
so they always have to be like this is
the hottest thing ever and this will
burn your face off and this isn't a kill
you up to Dianna hi
let's die mm-hmm okay I think to a lot
of people the idea of you and Eddie pong
and Action Bronson all hanging out
together it's like Emeril Lagasse and
Bobby Flay and you know I think would
blow a lot of people's minds okay I was
wonder you guys actually kick it you
guys actually hang out or is it like
everything else in this business we're
in the same room maybe once a year we
kick it Wow
yeah Eddie Eddie's the homie after this
show actually action action is amazing I
think that's spicy
okay um [ __ ] that's spicy respect hey
Ange is kind of taken in when I drink a
little milk it's hot who's the mouth
filled this is mm-hmm they just spread
it around in your mouth the milk spicy
milk you think you can escape it you
never can this is good I can't wait to
yeah those guys are great we text each
other we support each other um you know
Eddie like put me on blast about the
show and it's cool it's hot ah you know
Eddie did this show did he yeah it did
he do all of them so here's the most
interesting hot ones experience I think
of any guest we've ever had he tried to
flip the game you know how Eddie is with
structure knowing that he is with rules
so he doesn't like rules so close those
things out
he doesn't like them he goes I'm
starting hottest first okay so what he
did was he grabbed the hottest wing and
he cleaned it because he hadn't yet
learned to respect the sauces like
through the journey yeah learned to
respect the sauce but when you sit down
here you're kind of like aha
to be and so he cleans the first wing
and then I think he knew immediately
he's fired that was a mistake
yeah he was like in the bathroom he was
throwing up he did come back out and
finish the interview like a [ __ ]
champ I'll always come back daddy for
that but he made a big mistake going in
reverse order and like this way you're
like gradually and you're like getting
into it you're warming up and now you're
just like two [ __ ] left
spicy bomb tanking like smaller bites by
filler I should take Vikram ice in taste
like our metallic mm-hmm
does taste like metal and that's how you
know you're a delight yeah yeah this
[ __ ] up now [ __ ] up dog so you
dropped out of culinary school to tour
with a metal band yeah what's the worst
injury you ever suffered mobbing out at
a metal show I don't know I was never
the one getting hurt not to sound like a
big dummy but like I like I smashed some
dudes nose real bad how'd that go down I
was really drunk and I was like kind of
I guess pitting and I like went into the
crowd and just like elbowed really hard
and like dusted this guy's nose and
everyone was like kind of freaking out
and I was just drunk as I like so like
you know that guy's just like you're a
tower like this is what that's how it
goes yeah but I don't know like all that
stuff this is hard as [ __ ] mm-hmm yeah
this is it this is this is this is what
you've been waiting for
so do you wanna know I went to one
really hard metal show in my life so I
grew up in Chicago and there's this
place called fireside Bowl have you ever
heard of the fireside it's kind of this
like legendary venue okay
yeah it's this bowling alley at night
they'd rent it out to fans have you ever
heard of a group called Dillinger Escape
Plan yes I went to a Dillinger Escape
yeah and 23 percent burn best song it is
an awesome song great dad and then they
do this the only good song soup no they
do this a FX twin all clap think the my
pretty good yeah pindy yeah that's a
good that's good that's good project
yeah oh but here's the thing is it's not
for me like I got in there that was just
way too crazy it's way too intense the
punchin lights out everyone's going
insane and I was like I just have to
stand on the wall I can't deal with this
[ __ ] it is kind of crazy
is on Blairs Megadeth sauce with liquid
rage it is tradition around here to dab
the last wing so just get it so just get
it just get it shake it up you don't
have to if you don't want to but Maddie
I'm your [ __ ] cruisin see that's
[ __ ] up that's a [ __ ] up drop right
there so be careful into it I did
maybe yeah you probably have a technique
no just maybe later touching whoa oh
look a light touch okay be careful I
don't want that cuz Coolio did that and
he just doused the wing and then it's
fair because there's enough on here this
is for all the trolls out there thinking
that this is real [ __ ] hot sauce go
get [ __ ] but it's [ __ ] real you
come in here do this great idea for show
this is a great show I say the creature
Mandy do Manny do you mean it do you
mean it do you mean it do you mean it is
that patronizing no it's a great show
I'm I'm eating chicken wings learning
about myself talking about myself
experiencing you experiencing these
great people in the room complex is
great you know I thought I was gonna
walk around and like hang out with ASAP
Rocky talk about like for going shoes
and I didn't do that so nope sorry to
let you down
pinkies up on this one cheers but my
mother my my dude so
okay he's laughing the camp see now this
is [ __ ] up mm-hmm the crew all just
started kind of giggling after we ate
this they know what's up so you do the
best intros in the game and now that you
know a little bit about me and a little
bit about our show it would be such an
honor if you could give this show a
Matty Matheson intro so I want you to
introduce hot ones like you would do it
okay as you're dying on the wing and
then once you get through that It's A
Wrap
dying in the [ __ ] all right yep you
guys lose the Antoine chart - Antoine
dining the [ __ ] is great
you had [ __ ] hot sauce what the
[ __ ] a hot sauce chicken wings I got a
[ __ ] plane I don't give a [ __ ] about
the plate I'm here for chicken wings eat
me out world suck my dick hot sauce you
suck I'm out here complex Maddy math -
said world one milk what's up
worldwide peace ah now that's class walk
I'm Maddy it was so good the floor is
yours
this camera of that camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life I have an amazing life right
now have a TV show let's trap of many
restaurants very successful no see all
that stuff's fake that's what you say
I'm sad inside dark sometimes I'm
depressed I just want to stay at home
need Captain Crunch you know gotta get
real sometimes and just be yourself then
you have those moments of the big
triumphs and you get excited it's not
about the big wins it's about the small
wins small losses
you just live your life you come out on
top no matter how many times you fall
down get up live your life so maximize
be yourself be ya good I don't know when
why peace
you